Multiply (5a - 2)(4a^2 + 3a - 1)
So here we are multiplying a binomial by a trinomial
So the FOIL tool will not work here
It would only work if you were multiplying a binomial by another binomial
So here we really have to rely on the distributive property. What we can do is
we can distribute this entire trinomial onto the binomial. We we can multiply 4a^2
plus 3a -1 times 5a and then multiply (4a^2 + 3a -1) times -2.
So that would give us, let me do it this way. That would give us 5a times 4a^2 +3a -1
and then we would have a plus -2 times 4a^2 plus 3a -1. I've just distributed this
onto each term over here you see the 5a -2 each term is now being multiplied by this entire thing.
And now we can distribute the 5a onto this term. So we have 5a times 4a^2.
So we can multiply the 5 times the 4 we get 20. a times the a^2 is a^3. Then we do
5a times 3a. 5 times 3 is fifteen. a times a is a^2.
Then we have 5a times -1, well thats just going to be -5a. Now we do this part,
Plus -2 times 4a^2. -2 times four is -8a^2. So we just did that...
-2 times 3a is -6a. And then finally you have -2 times -1. Well a negative times a negative is a positive.
So that is postive 2 and now we can combine like terms.
We only have one ^3 term over here. We only have the 20a^3. So lets just write that down.
And then lets look at our a^2 terms we have a 15a^2 right over here and we have another
-8a^2. So if I have 15 of something and I subtract 8 from that then I have 7 of that something left.
So 15 minus 8 is 7. And then we have a -5a. And to that we're going to add -6a.
So we are already -5 and to that we're going to be another -6.
We going to be 6 more negative. So that is -11a. And then finally we have this constant out here.
We have this plus 2. No I'll show you another way to get this exact same answer.
We are done. We have simplified, and we have combined all our like terms.
Another way to do this is just like doing the distributive property twice. But it's essentially
more analogous to how we multiply numbers. So if we do it like this we could take this
expression up here. We could take 4a^2 plus 3a -1. And then multiply it by this second expression.
So times.... and I'll write it in the same places.. and when I say places. I'm not saying
powers of ten, I'm saying powers of a. So this is in the first a power of a space.
So 5a, see we have first powers of a in this space. Minus 2 this is the zeroth power of a.
This a to zeroth place instead of the ones place. This is the a to the first power
instead of the tens place. And this is a to the square power instead of the hundreds place.
Completely analogous to what you do when you learn to multiply numbers in the first
or second grade. So let's multiply these. First we'll multiply -2 by this entire thing.
Remember we're just essentially doing the distributive property. When I multiply -2 by this entire thing
I'm doing this step right over here. So -2 times -1 is positive 2. And once again theres no a there.
So I'm going to write this in the a^0 place or the ones place.
So it's going to be positive 2. -2 times 3a. Well that is -6a. And it's going to be in the a place.
-6a, a to the first power place. And then -2 times 4a^2, well that's just going to be -8a^2.
So this is-2 being multiplied by all of that gives me this. And then when I take my 5a and I multiply
it by -1 that going to be -5a. That's going to the a place, that goes under a like term.
then 5a times 3a, 5 times 3 is 15 and a times a is a^2. So it goes under the other a^2.
So it's 15a^2 and then finally 5a times 4a^2 . 5 times 4 is 20. a times a^2 is a^3. So you have 20a^3.
And now you can just add it all up. And we get 2 plus nothing is 2. -6a -5a well that's just -11a
We still have this plus 2 here. -8a^2 plus 15a^2 well thats going to be 7a^2.
So plus 7a^2. And then you're adding this to nothing so you have 20a^3. And we got the exact same answer.
Cause we really did the same exact thing we just wrote it in a different way.